france
hugo houle se rapproche de son objectif
remporter une étape du tour déjà
dimanche il avait fait partie de
l'échappée de la 9e étape vendredi en
route vers la ville de saint-etienne où
il a tenté le coup à nouveau il n'est
pas passé très loin de la victoire alema
peterson qui se retourne à 12 kilomètres
de l'arrivée il à résister à une attaque
du danois match pederson il a collé sa
roue à celle du britannique frank wright
pour pouvoir revenir sur le danois
j'étais content d'avoir ça prend la roue
cas les attaques et l'info plage parce
que surpris un peu tout le monde la
barrette a bien réagi white du coup j'ai
sauté et beaucoup que ce sera après là
bas c'était mieux houle bien en jambes a
pris ses relais et a pu disputer le
sprint final alors que le québécois mené
le petit groupe pederson a lancé son
attaque à 3 111 mètres de l'arrivée et
bien servi par son gabarit a tenu bon
jusqu'à l'arrivée où il a fini 3e
[Musique]
et cool bondé final c'est claque contre
matt petersen
makossa ses crocs clic un peu mais je
très satisfaits de la façon d'un gic
aujourd'hui je pense que je peux pas
vraiment faire mieux
avant cette troisième place hugo houle
avait fini 7e de la 12e étape du tour en
2020 derniers efforts sur les champs
elysées le seul canadien à avoir
remporté une étape du tour de france
c'est steve bauer en 1988 très
clairement plus gourou lé veut être le
prochain et troisième victoire d'étape
pour les ici philippe crépeau radio
canada montréal